hi there today we're looking at do
imagenet classifiers generalized to
imagenet by Benjamin wrecked Rebecca or
Olaf's Ludwig Schmidt and vishal shankar
so the premise of this paper is pretty
simple we've been training models on
imagenet now for a while almost 10 years
to be exact image net is this data set
with a lot of images millions of images
and categorized into many thousands of
categories now the the classic part of
image net that people know is that has
about 1.5 million images in 1,000
different classes and this image net was
one of the main data sets now or has
been for the last few years and as you
can see on the right here the error rate
year after year was pretty much I think
cut in half every year since 2012 when
the first net Alex net was using deep
learning instead of the classic aural
visual computer vision approaches so
we've been training on image net for a
while and the idea or the question this
paper asks if we collect a second test
set
right so for image net we have a train
and a test set if we now collect a
second test set here test v2 right if we
have a model that was trained on
training here and evaluated on test does
it also perform well on this second test
set right the idea of this being that
maybe over the years we've tuned our
hyper parameters and all such that the
models perform well on that particular
test set let's call this v1 right and it
might not it might not be as successful
on a new test set so this paper goes
about collecting a test set to imagenet
in exactly the way that the v1 test said
was collected right
so they they try to match exactly the
process of how we won was collected to
create another test set and then they
evaluate models on that new test set
they do this not only for imagenet but
also for CFR 10 which is a much smaller
data set but also a lot of computer
vision algorithms are evaluated on CFR
10 so let's just put up a hypothesis
here the hypothesis is that we have
pretty much over fitted to image net by
now this is a very prestigious number to
get if you have state of the art on
image net and therefore tuning your
hyper parameters and your learning rate
and everything such that it performs
well on the test set v1 is very likely
so this paper has the most important
plots are like this it has two axes and
on the bottom axis is the performance on
v1 right and so performance and that
means accuracy basically so accuracy and
on line two is v2 accuracy now here is
one here is zero this line here means
that if a model is performing 50%
accuracy on v1 it is also performing 50%
accuracy on v2 so being on this line
would basically mean we have not over
fit it and the model is performing
equally well on both both sets so what
what now if we assume that we have over
fitted if we have over fitted we would
assume that you know the models that
perform really poorly might also you
know they perform kind of they're not
really over fitted but over the years as
we've gotten better on v1 we stray away
from this so we get better on v1 but we
don't really get better on v2 right and
that means we've over fitted to v1 and
this might even go down right the more
the more kind of we might over fit to v1
the worse we're actually gonna get on v2
so this this is kind of a meta
over-fitting so this is what we would
expect if we over fit right o-over fit
to vivo one and I think this was the
initial hypothesis behind the people
that ran this experiment to check can we
see an effect like this or is the effect
more a continuous one where we don't
over fit and what they found was neither
and these are basically these
interesting plots here so again the
dashed line here would be the not over
fitting line so what they find if you
for example look at image that every dot
here is a model right so this model
right here is performing with like a
sixty seven percent accuracy on v1 and
it is performing with something like a
fifty three percent accuracy on v2 if
you look at this line here what that
means is every model kind of drops by
about this much right so not only not we
don't see this and we don't see this but
we see this line is shifted down and if
you look closely especially on c4 ten
you can see the line rather than being
tilted like this is actually tilted a
bit slanted upwards right so the the the
angle is not is higher is greater the
slope is greater than the one to one
slope this is extremely interesting if
you think about what does that mean it
means that if you take a model right
right here if you look at its order it's
it's it's a this let's let's look at
this model here this model is number one
best model in the world right it will
still be number one on v2 this model
here is number of number three ranked
three on v1 it will also be ranked three
on v2
right so the older of models is is
pretty much constant so if a model was
doing well on v1 it is also doing well
on v2 in relation to other models but
every model experiences this drop in in
accuracy and the most interesting part
is that and again you can see this more
here the the better you're doing the
smaller this drop gets right this drop
here is smaller than this drop here this
is exactly counter to the notion of
overfitting where it seems the more
accurate you get on v1 the more you're
able to close this gap between v1 and v2
and if you extrapolate here you might as
well think that once we are at at or
actually sorry
100% is already here if you could go
high maybe or maybe you can see here
that in the end the these will actually
converge but nevertheless if the models
that are doing better on v1 aren't only
not over fit but they are actually
experienced less of a drop with regards
to a new test at so they generalize
better to the new test set then the the
worst models right and that is crazy and
it is not only neural networks right so
up here for you up here you have the the
deep neural networks and whatnot but you
can also go with I believe some of these
or even further down here our K nearest
neighbor sorry K nearest neighbor
classifiers and things like this so it
doesn't seem to be a property of neural
networks it really seems to be a
property of the data set in this paper
first of all goes over how they
collected these and second of all their
hypotheses and investigations into why
and this phenomenon exists why we are
all of a sudden worse on the new
test set but completely worse in a
different way than we expected compared
to the original test set all right so
they first say potential causes of an of
accuracy drops and they propose a model
they say here are two here is the entire
difference between two data sets with
regards to a classifier it can be
decomposed into three different gaps and
you see the first and the last part here
are the ones from the left side so this
is an expanding sum in the middle so
there is the generalization gap the
generalization gap refers to the gap
that you have between different data
sets of the same distribution so these
this is like you know from the Train
versus test set you train on the
training set and then you have a
generalization gap to the test set in
this case the generalization gap simply
refers to the difference between the
generalization to the first into the
second set they argue that this isn't
really an issue here because the because
the they say the D confident they can
put up confidence intervals so if those
were identically distributed how much
would the generalization gap be at
maximum given some kind of confidence
interval 95% confidence interval would
only give you plus minus a 1% difference
in generalization gaps so they rule out
that this is the reason for the big
discrepancy then have two others they
have the adaptivity gap and the
distribution gap so the adaptivity gap
is what we hypothesized at the beginning
it is the overfitting to the first data
set or to one of the two data sets so if
you have a big adaptivity gap
then you have Oh fitted much more to one
than to the other data set now because
of the shape of the curve being the way
it is they also rule out the adaptivity
gap and we went over why right because
it would look completely different than
it does now the only thing remaining
here is this distribution gap so they
explained that this difference here most
likely comes from the fact fact that the
old and the new test set have a
different distribution and they go into
why that is and I'm going to compress
the I'm going to compress they're sort
of hypotheses of why that is into a into
a short summary let's say we won't go
over the entire paper they basically say
that the Mechanical Turk has a the
Mechanical Turk part of the processing
pipeline has a very big influence so
what happens when you collect an image
net test that you start with flickr this
is a big image database and the images
as far as i can understand they they are
tagged and you can search for them and
so on so they start by going to flickr
and surging searching for images and
their ground truth class labels come you
may know this from a system called world
net and word net is sort of a linguistic
classification of words into groups so
it would would have hierarchically would
have animals animal being a word and
then below animal it would have dog and
then it would have terrier and it would
have these hierarchical groupings of
these words and the search on flickr for
images and then they put images to a
human rater
so the human rater in on a system called
Mechanical Turk you may know it that you
can just sign up there and do these kind
of tasks they present the human with a
grid of images and a class Terrier and
they say please select all the images
where a terrier appears so the human
might select this this this and this one
right and that will give you what they
call a selection frequency so selection
frequency so how often was a particular
image selected given that class and of
course the higher so you do this over
many sorry the selection frequency is
across many of these Mechanical Turk
workers so if for a given image the
selection frequency is high let's say
going towards one point zero that means
every single human selected that image
to be in the in this class so you can be
pretty sure it's in the class if it goes
towards zero then you can be pretty sure
it's not in the class and this selection
frequency criterium the paper thinks
that this is the main criterion why the
data sets are of different of different
difficulties let's say because even even
though they try to match the process
exactly even what the questions they
post to the turk workers they even
restricted their flicker date range to
the date range where the original image
net was collected they still think that
there is a difference in how the
Mechanical Turk workers basically rated
the images or then after that how they
were selected using the selection
frequency so what they do is they do
different they select different images
depending on criteria so they can test
these hypotheses their original v2
test set is called matched frequency now
what you do in matched frequency is you
kind of play a little game what you do
is every now and then you will implant
an image here of the v1 test set so
thereby and of the v1 test set either of
this class or of another class so you
can kind of do a quality control in from
this you can now find out what is the
selection frequency of images in the v1
class for Terrier and then you can
simply select the same one in the v2
right so if if you know the selection
frequency for v1 was 0.8 you can just
put the threshold here at 0.8 and you
know you can be reasonably sure that you
have selected a similar difficulty or so
you would think right so if they do it
like this then they get this drop that
you saw at the beginning they also do
this threshold 0.7 which I guess is
arbitrary ish and then they also say top
images where where they say for each
class we chose the 10 images with the
highest selection frequency so these
would be the sort of easiest easiest
ones and if you look at the graphs and
this is image net for these different
data sets so if you do the threshold
point 7 that they selected now the old
line was somewhere here now the new line
is much closer right you see that here
and if you do these top images so you
just select the easy ones the new line
is actually above right this is now note
note that the red line here is above the
black line while here it's below it is
still extremely interesting
that still there is this almost linear
relationship between the v1 and v2
accuracies and even here on this easier
dataset there is so they basically
hypothesized by threshold in
for the new data set you can you have a
very good grip on the difficulty of the
new of the new data set and so this
process of matching the selection
frequency so this matched frequency data
set it might actually not result in the
same difficulty in data set they do have
some more experiments where they
experiment with different if different
difficulties so let's actually jump down
there it's a bit of a jump because there
are over 70 pages in this paper the
appendix has its own content directory
that's how crazy that is
but I want to show you these plots
so here what they do is they do
different bins of the of this set so
they have bins of easy samples less easy
samples and so on and you can see that
you have a pretty good grip on this
where this line is so if you only take
the easy samples you're up here and this
is about what we saw before if this is
the old line is the red line right if
you take the entire new test set if you
just take bin the second hardest bin
you're somewhere here or here or here so
you have a good you have a good hold on
where this line is but it still doesn't
explain that if you try to follow the
protocol exactly why does the accuracy
drop that that is still a mystery even
though they say here is a variable that
influences this a lot if they try to set
the variable as it was set
in v1 it is not equal so the still
mystery remains I would say so the last
thing they do is they try to to just
come up with a model for this so their
hypothesis now is that the new test set
just is harder and they have a
analytical kind of a formal model of why
if you assume certain things
this results in this line right the the
the really interesting thing about the
paper is that the the accuracies they
all fall exactly on this line there is
this linear relationship especially they
say if you do like probate scaling of
accuracies there's this line and so they
put up a model where you say what if we
assume that each example I has a
difficulty right it's just a number how
difficult it is and each model J has a
probability of correctly classifying an
image with difficulty tau here given by
this function right so this here is the
probability that the model will classify
an image correctly giving that it's too
hard and so this is an increasing
function and they put up this following
parameterization these this is the CDF
of the so they put up a model for this
function now right for this they say if
we assume that it is like this that each
model has a sort of a skill number so
each model has a skill and each image
has a difficulty that is tau if we if
the skill is higher than the tau
probably will classify correctly if the
skill is lower
probably then this number is negative it
will classify it incorrectly so this is
the CDF of a normal distribution it goes
something like this right and if these
the zero point is here so if this number
here is zero it's like 50/50 whether it
will classify it correctly so if you
assume this and you assume a bunch of
other Gaussian error distributions then
the the difficult this already
performance of a model on the tests at
v2 is exactly the performance of the
model under tests at v1 times this
scalar here plus this scalar here which
is a linear relationship so they put up
a model for for this of course it
doesn't explain anything right this
doesn't explain the phenomena but they
it still gives a clue of why the linear
relationship here might result from the
test set having a different difficulty
setting or a different difficulty
properties so they go on after
discussing related work they go on to
say what can one do and suggestions for
future research I especially like the
the super holdout so if you ever make a
data set if you ever make a data set
then make a super holdout set and once
you're like almost out of your career
just come up with it and say oh I have
this lost data set here that I made way
back it will be fantastic alright so I
think this paper is very interesting and
I think everyone that sees and reads
this comes up with their own hypotheses
of why this is and what's going on here
they have invested
a lot of this especially I want to
highlight an experiment where they taken
part of v2 here so they split this one
into a train and the test sorry
train and a test and they put this in
this training together into like a super
train right so so you train on both
things together and they see whether it
improves at this test set right you
would think that if you put this
training in there that it would improve
and it does improve but it improves by
like a miniscule amount and so they've
done a whole bunch experiments like this
to investigate what's going on this is
all in this 70 page appendix that you
can go over right that was what I had to
say for this paper if you like this
video consider subscribing and comment
what have you think I usually answer or
like or read most comments thanks for
listening bye bye